hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to slender the gaze of
horror it dawned on me that I have not
played a slender game in so long that
people have kind of forgotten what
Slender was all about and I used to
played extensively just because it was a
huge thing as big as five nights as
Freddy is today
slender was bigger before if you can
even believe it actually I don't know
it's comparable to which one is actually
bigger but this one is a slender game
that was made relatively recently that
actually looks a little bit interesting
there's some different things that I saw
in the images going on that may not be
that terrible compared to some of the
bad ones
trapped in your worst nightmare you wake
up in the middle of the night in an
abandoned Asylum oh boy
frightened and accompanied by a dreadful
sigh okay I'm not done what alright then
you read that right find the eight pages
now this is the typical slender game
type oh oh my well this is my abandoned
Asylum eh oh it looks very rustic rustic
in this order I'm about to get tetanus
kind of wane on the good old home style
that I've come to know in love it
honestly has been an exceptionally long
time oh hello whoa what is that it is a
mutilated corpse goodie I was wondering
when I was gonna see the decorations of
this place
I love the color palette choice blood
and rust very good now like I said it's
been a long time - whoa my god
no one's gonna clean up after themselves
what a dump my goodness
plunder seems to be in doing a lot more
mutilation than I remember him doing
what am I supposed to make out of all of
this yeah this is what I noticed when I
owned notice the images because it was a
lot more bloody and gory than i've
noticed before and also did I mention
I'm here alone and recording it like
3:00 in the morning again some people
have get it I don't even know what the
page looks like why is my light
flickering already
it's the Slenderman gonna come out and
play like I used to be legitimately
terrified at the Slenderman and the
games really really scared me it's weird
being back in a new one that I have not
played in a long time anyway what I'm
saying for is it some people have
guessed I am in the grumps recording
space the game grumps I have let me use
their space because my internet is still
not set up at home and they have a
really lovely couch it it's very
comfortable and I like it a lot I don't
know what I'm doing in this game some
people were panicking
some people said I was homeless and it's
like not no no not not at all it's like
I what why would you even I appreciate
the concern but what anyway so I'm not
homeless I'm not anything like that
nothing horrible happened my internet is
out so I'm just peeling away hanging out
with the game grumps who I love very
dearly and if you haven't watched them
yet my god what are you doing with your
life what's the game grumps they're
hilarious also I did a pole dancing
video with them but that's besides the
point I'm worried about the Slenderman I
have not found one god damn page I don't
even know the pages look like you're
awfully meaty mmm
I like that about my random assortment
of dead bodies that I find in an
abandoned Asylum meatiness I remember
probably the most terrifying Slenderman
game that I ever played even one that
wasn't made by quote-unquote the
official maker Mark J Hadley I think his
name is who made the original one was
slender than nine pages Lee I don't know
what it was about that video but you can
check it out for yourself I'll link it
in the description but that particular
video scared Jesus you need to stop
making noise over there not literal
Jesus goddamn that window behind you
freaks me out every time I play horror
games it reminds me that I'm alone I'm
just sitting here by myself or at least
I'm hope I'm alone god it would be even
worse if someone was actually here okay
I'm gonna go non-us you're gonna do
something to me stop flicker in my life
need that to be able to see things there
god damn page you have a page sir it's a
goddamn pages place is so big it's gonna
be impossible to find damn page not a
page is this a page okay big double
doors is this promising wow that okay I
walked into a bad place I know when I
said promising I wasn't counting on all
of this god ah page don't look at it I
thought it was don't look at him he
turned into an it oh hey why am I
looking at him was I looking at him you
did exactly what the page da whoa you're
big
oh you're big and red goodness I'm
clipping the microphone like a
son-of-a-bitch but goddamn Oh God oh my
goodness
I barely got a glimpse of ya I want to
get another
No thank you sir goddamn that wasn't
terribly on the obvious everything is
just a slight sheet of brown uh hey the
dead guy good
oh did I just I went in a circle didn't
it but he's not here is he okay good
good good good good I guess so I got one
page he took me like five minutes to get
a single page that does not bode well
for me oh wait oh god it was on the back
of this guy I'm scared
well I'm not cuz I'm brave I'm worried
about no Slendy man should I be though
wondering if I should be well this is
the back end of the place where I just
was were but there's no page here
goddamn these pages are hard to find I
mean I don't blame this game for
following the collecting pages Ruth that
is the standard slender gameplay I mean
whether you want to say that there needs
to be an evolution on the subject that's
what it was so it's obviously that all
the fan emulations of it are gonna
follow the same route I would like a bit
more in intricate Ness
okay so that light was this frickin
flickering pic fake flickering you know
what I meant well I seem to have lost
Slendy man I guess that's a good thing I
only barely caught a glimpse of him he
got so red when I was first looking at
him that I wasn't able to do anything
else god this is convoluted as hell it
all looks the same it's just a bunch of
looping corridors it all look the same
how am I supposed to be able to get any
landmarks know where I am
god no way what the [ __ ] [ __ ] you're
ugly
holy crap get away from me Oh Paige it's
coming it's coming
the Slendy man I know it's bad okay like
what up get away I don't want to mess
with you I got other plans so suddenly
like after a long period of not finding
any pages I'm suddenly finding all the
pages how what am i doing differently
how am I gonna survive in the crazy
world goddamn I'm getting turned around
again aren't I
I think I'm just taking the wrong
oh-o-oh behind me that's not something
you say to me when I'm stuck in a narrow
corridor man oh this bed is bad okay I'm
not mistaken I feel like I might have
been here before but how can I know how
can I know anything goddamn you
god damn yo
hey get away from me sir
extreme stranger danger yes after he's
not happy he's not happy with me I used
to be able to beat almost all of the
Slenderman games as they gain out suffer
I think slender prison threw me for a
loop without that one was unfair that
one was ridiculously hard you know what
I mean not my fault I'm not a baby baby
I'm a man I'm a manly man it's a ceiling
made of meat it's a ceiling me to me I
feel like the ceiling and or the floor
or walls might be made of meat at some
point what what what what there's a bit
of colorful green grass here that
doesn't make any sense of all this is a
bunch of urban death and oh that's right
it was green grass here whoa where did I
go why am i outside don't tell me there
are pages out here I've been fooling
around inside there when that could have
come outside in any moment oh it's an
inner courtyard she is going on here oh
there might be a page out here though
looks like I'm locked in
good thing there's still dead bodies all
around I would have felt out of place
without him maybe there wasn't no that's
a dead body that's a dead body
ah right I right as rain wrong is wrong
get away from me it's no page out here
is this where I'm supposed to go when
I'm done least I know I finally looked
back to where I was god damn how am I
supposed to find a package
you're this big I know I'll go this way
then excuse me pardon I think I'm
officially out of sprint juice I can't
go for more than a few seconds oh come
on give me a page I need four more
there's no way I'm gonna be able to find
him in this place God I am God I am whoa
what where are you where are you okay he
was over there oh look I made the lucky
correct choice couldn't exactly see
where he was god damn it no Beezus stop
hi
whoa God I saw the reflection of what
was going on in the game within the
window by me that actually startled me
oh my god I'm getting paranoid now and
not because of this game
well broad because partly of this game
ah well like I'm going nowhere
what's that a peach oh this is the giant
collection of dead bodies Oh what does
that mean for me means I looked around
and again and I can't find the damn
things okay these are the doors that led
from the inner courtyard but I don't
know if that does anything for me kind
of gives me an idea where I end though
so I guess it's good oh god damn it I'm
so lost just you know what kill me kill
me
Oh
well then overwhelmed by the horrors of
your worst nightmare you lost your mind
in your emotions and from that moment on
your soul was condemned to terror and
suffering oh man I was wandering around
for a long time there don't you worry
about me I I don't know if you guys
might have seen a page that I walked
past but it was really hard to notice
anything at all
hey look it's all eight pages I found
them
oh boy well there you go slender the
gaze of or it wasn't that terrible but
to be honest it wasn't what I was
expecting when I saw the screenshots
there was a lot of really intricate
detail that was portrayed but it was
repeated too many times to be able to
give me a clear sense of where I was
however whose spooky I'm still in this
weird room and there's a goddamn window
by me that I keep hearing noises you
probably can't hear it but I do so thank
you all so much for watching and check
out all the other slender games that
I've played you don't know about slender
oh man you're in for a treat but some of
you probably do so check out the
playlist in the description over there
down below in the comment or than the
descriptor whatever you know what I mean
or the annotation over there thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye-bye the last scenario Granholm so so
in this lake house in upstate New York
in the castle and I'm dead again
Wow